hide your daughters lock up your wives
the lesbians are coming to your town
I'm dr. Martin and I'm here to tell you
about the dangers of homosexuality see
these girls here they look harmless
enough but what you can't see is they're
all lesbians lesbians are seductresses
who will sleep with other women by
choice I only sleep with my wife because
I have to they are dangerous creatures
don't believe me take Mary here Mary is
a senior at Lincoln High School top of
the class editor of the yearbook and the
best darn softball player Lincoln High
has ever seen
she teaches Bible study after school and
has never had a boyfriend because she's
saving herself for the perfect man the
ideal daughter that would make any
father proud today there is a new girl
in school Jenny out of the kindness of
her heart Mary will befriend Jenny but
what Mary doesn't know is Jenny is a
lesbian you must be the new girl yeah
I'm Shirley it's so very nice to meet
you what are some things you do for fun
Jenny play music music golly I love
music
what kind I'm like indie rock kind of
like Tegan and Sara you know Jenny Lewis
are those help friends of yours no
there's just other musicians my never
heard of women playing rock music before
I sure love to come here you play
sometime
sure yeah and just like that the lesbian
has managed to slither into Mary's life
Mary found herself researching rock
music which has always been prohibited
by her parents and she would begin to
act out but mother in the honeymooners
when ralph threatens Alice by saying to
the moon
that's domestic violence and no woman
should stand for that Mary was heading
down a dark hole and things were only
getting worse I really just want to be a
writer after high school but my father
says I should just go to nursing school
until I find a husband to support me
what that do
you want you can't use language like
that so raunchy I'm just saying
live your life carpe diem Yolo the
lesbian will continue to seduce your
daughter with words of encouragement and
by treating them with respect well sorry
I don't know what came over me
you really razz my berries Jennifer once
she gives in to the temptation there is
no going back as lesbians are very
attentive lovers who will commit to
women for long periods of time lesbians
live in a world of chaos and debauchery
and while Mary should be out at her
school's football games supporting her
team instead she is in for the night
making deep connections with Jenny and
bonding over common interests like a
sick human being it's quite a shame to
see how quickly our young Mary was
turned into a homosexual and I was
definitely gay the whole time yes that's
what the lesbians are forcing you to say
because you're still under their spell
you can't turn someone gay yeah they're
been actual studies that people are born
I am no longer listening to either of
you and neither should you beware the
lesbians
you
so what are you doing up to this it's
here it's here
what get it you're there there's a very
fine I got it get it yeah you get it
it's here quick